dijon sans ma voiture qu'est ce que
c'est mais d'autres en mars
on invite les habitants de gigean
métropole à nous confier leurs voitures
et à déceler les mobilités alternatives
en contrepartie tous les services
d'hygiène mobilité sont offert des
avantages également avec l'auto partage
via cities le vélo la trottinette
électrique et le covoiturage
quel est l'objectif de cette opération
l'objectif c'est une expérience de vie à
de se mettre en condition réelle pour
tester d'un point de vue pratique toutes
les mobilités et voir s'il est possible
de vivre sans voiture a dit jean
métropole dijon sans ma voiture
est ce que ça marche on le verra au 30
mars ils vous invitent au bilan mais en
tout cas aujourd'hui voilà on a 60 foyer
dijonnais une centaine de personnes
comparativement à 2016 nous avions 30
familles